[Musique]
et
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau vip
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec ségolène
perron bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
yvelinoise artiste plasticienne ici on à
la maison de l'étudiant à guyancourt
représenter une exposition qui s'appelle
mégapixels qu'est ce qu'on peut voir
alors dans cette exposition on peut voir
des peintures des photographies et des
vitrophanies la vitrophanie c'est une
technique qui est moins connu qui
consiste à coller des autocollants
transparents sur les vitres pour obtenir
une sorte d'effet vitrail s'il ya la
lumière qui joue c'est ça oui tout à
fait j'ai collé des carrés de couleurs
et la lumière du soleil qui circulent
dans l'escalier de la maison de
l'étudiant plutôt du matin jusque vers
15h permet de voir le bain les couleurs
se projeter sur le sol et sur les murs
de l'espace d'exposition ce qui
m'enchante à chaque fois et les photos
alors qu'il a sur le mur c'est quoi
alors les photos je les appelle des
photos color ce sont des photos que j'ai
prises
ben pas très loin de la maison de
l'étudiant puisque moi-même j'habite pas
loin et que c'est vraiment à la fois
l'environnement quotidien des étudiants
mais aussi le mien en fait
et donc j'ai pris ces photos à
différentes saisons et les prises de vue
sont associés là encore à des filtres de
couleurs donc sûr
1 mon ordinateur je décide d'associer un
carré de couleur que je superpose à la
photographie partiellement et ce qui
fait que il ya une sorte de dégrader de
l'image figurative vers une surface
colorée unis n'ont qu'à une sorte de
deux passages à l'abstraction qui
m'intéresse beaucoup
parce que dans ma pratique en fait qui
est plus à coude streit quand je suis
peintre
je suis par contre plus réaliste
forcément avec la photographie donc
voilà ça c'est un les photos que l'on me
permette d'associer en fait deux façons
de voir les choses et de voir la couleur
est donc cette exposition a lieu dans le
cadre d'un partenariat avec le service
culturel de l'université vous exposer
aussi à la bibliothèque universitaire
c'est quoi la base qu'on peut voir alors
en fait à la bibliothèque universitaire
j'ai fait une installation de
vitrophanie donc ce projet s'appelle
suite chromatique
ce sont les mêmes couleurs que j'ai
utilisée pour les stickers de la
bibliothèque que ceux de la maison de
l'étudiant
l'idée c'est de mettre un de faire un
lien un lien visuel en fait entre les
bâtiments du campus est d'ailleurs ce
projet est toujours en cours puisque le
jeu doit aussi en place et des stickers
dans le hall vauban mais pour le moment
voilà c'est en cours il faut que je
fasse une formation nacelle pour monter
plus haut en tout cas à la bibliothèque
universitaire que ce soit au rez de
chaussée ou dans les salles de travail à
laitages il y a également des stickers
qui joue avec la lumière solaire et
également avec le paysage c'est à dire
que quand on regarde le paysage à
travers ces stickers et bien on retrouve
un petit peu finalement l'effet que je
cherche à donner dans les photos color
c'est à dire qu'on voit le paysage avec
un filtre coloré par dessus et ça ça
m'intéresse beaucoup et donc vous êtes
aussi et professeur à l'université des
beaux-arts de versailles ce qui est une
volonté de transmettre
ah oui ça c'est sûr oui oui
je tiens beaucoup à la pédagogie je
tiens beaucoup à l échange avec les
étudiants et jeudi échange parce qu'en
fait c'est pas seulement une
transmission que je peux faire dans le
cadre de mes cours c'est aussi dans les
deux sens les les étudiants m'apporte
énormément remettre en question les
connaissances que j'ai la façon de voir
le monde donc c'est en plus dans mon
école c'est particulièrement
intergénérationnel il y à des étudiants
de tous âges et
et l'échangé très riche et d'ailleurs
c'est un étudiant de l'école à qui j'ai
demandé de faire le time lapse de la
vitrophanie mégapixels qui en bas de
l'escalier de la maison de l'étudiant
parce qu'il est vraiment très doué pour
ça il a une sensibilité avec laquelle je
m'accorde complètement et du coup ben
voilà les étudiants sont les premiers
artistes avec qui je vis au quotidien
donc tu absolument passionné par
l'enseignement oui et alors pour
l'université est fermée
les étudiants ont pas pu voir
l'exposition ou alors très peu
comment vous vous ressentez vous êtes
cette impossibilité cette difficulté à
montrer votre travail
alors bien sûr rien comme pour tout le
monde
une certaine forme de frustration voire
de tristesse a pas pouvoir voir les
oeuvres en vrai et on est impatient de
retrouver
voilà des délais format des oeuvres la
texture des oeuvres leur matière ça
c'est sûr on est très impatients de ça
ça nous manque beaucoup
en même temps on est créatif donc on a
mis vraiment en place plein de façons de
montrer son travail d'une autre manière
des conférences en ligne des expositions
en ligne des façons de créer alors pour
nos étudiants par exemple des des
dossiers dans lesquels on voit leurs
travaux donc finalement je trouve que
sur internet en ce moment il y a plein
de documents qui sont disponibles et qui
n'étaient pas forcément réaliser ou
formulées avant donc voilà l'aspect
positif c'est qu'on a beaucoup de
documentation votre atelier il a vu que
vous avez toujours décrit dans les
yvelines alors pas toujours il se trouve
que enfants j'ai vécu un moment à buc ça
c'est assez étonnant je suis un peu
revenu sur ce lieu là
mais j'ai fait un long détour par le sud
de la france et où j'ai vu la très belle
lumière du sud
ça c'est vrai que je pense c'est quelque
chose d'assez fondamental dans mon
travail et aussi où j'ai découvert
vraiment l'art dans dans sa forme
professionnelle parce que j'habitais
avignon avignon c'est une ville déjà
magnifique 1,1 point de vue
architectural mais aussi une ville où il
ya un festival tout à fait passionnant
de théâtre de danse et d'arts visuels
aussi du coup en fait j'ai eu la chance
de pouvoir faire mes jobs d'été dans le
festival d'avignon de côtoyer les
artistes et je crois que sans cette
ville je vois là je n'aurais peut-être
pas eu le courage de devenir artiste
parce que c'est quand même une décision
qu'il faut mature et qui voilà qui qui
est qui est forte
les voilà donc je pense que ça vient
quand même d'avignon qu'est ce qui vous
a poussé justement à devenir artiste
c'était une volonté depuis que vous
étiez petit
alors j'ai eu la chance que ma mère soit
très intéressé par l'art et la peinture
elle même elle a une courte période de
sa vie donner des petits ateliers d'arts
plastiques à des enfants et j'adorais
aller l'aider à nettoyer le matériel
donc j'ai nettoyé les palettes de
couleurs je regardais l'eau qui passait
comme ça dans le tourbillon du vortex de
l'évier
et en fait je crois que c'est à peu près
à ce moment là que j'ai commencé
vraiment à aimer la couleur et donc vous
avez pu exposer dans d'autres pays
encore et notamment pourquoi vous avez
fait ce choix alors il se trouve que
dans mon école il y a beaucoup
d'étudiants qui viennent d'asie
et j'ai aussi une de mes collègues qui
est coréenne
donc c'est par son intermédiaire que
j'avais pu aller pour la première fois
en corée en 2011 et ce pays m'a vraiment
ouvert les yeux sur un autre monde et en
plus au sud de la corée du sud
les couleurs sont particulièrement
vivante
donc il ya des marchés il ya une façon
de s'habiller aussi assez libre
vis-à-vis de la couleur
donc quand j'ai pu faire toutes ses
résidences puisque j'en ai fait quatre à
ce jour j'ai à chaque fois vraiment pu
profiter de l'énergie de la couleur qui
est je trouve davantage présente en
corée du sud qu'en france voilà qu'est
ce que vous avez appris de ça et qu'elle
était le retour sur votre travail de
personnes venant d'une culture
différente est ce que l'art est
universel alors l'art visuel je pense
est sans doute quelque chose qu'il est
plus facile de passer d'une culture à
l'autre même si certains codes sont
différents mais c'est vrai que en corée
du sud par exemple il ya une tradition
de patchwork on appelle le pot jaggi qui
sont des tissus très très coloré et avec
des formes géométriques qui m'ont
beaucoup plu en fait et qui ont inspiré
une des vitrophanies qu j'ai pu faire là
bas sinon j'ai eu la chance aussi de
pouvoir peindre sur des papiers coréen
qui sont des papiers traditionnels donc
des papiers qui ont une qualité
d'absorption de la couleur qui me plaît
beaucoup en fait
et puis ces papiers là on peut les plier
comme des tissus alors ça ça m'a
vraiment beaucoup plus parce que le
papier en auxi
c'est plutôt sur des feuilles qui sont
un peu tranchante ou des rouleaux qui
sont assez costaud et le papier coréens
qu'ils se pliaient que je peux me mettre
dans ma valise parce que j'allais là-bas
en avion eh ben c'est ça influence est
effectivement ma pratique de peintres ça
c'est sûr et donc vous avez fondé une
association qui s'appelle des astres
associés c'est une association pour le
développement et la diffusion de l'art
qui est laid l'objet quel est le but
premier
alors cette association c'est une fête
une structure qui me permet de
travailler dans le cadre de mes
différents projets et aussi parfois avec
d'autres artistes à un moment j'avais
fait des performances avec un musicien
avec un batteur donc voila c'était
d'aider des grands formats que je
faisais au son de la musique
j'ai travaillé aussi avec d'autres
artistes par exemple dans les écoles de
guyancourt donc à chaque fois cette
structure me permets de de valider une
organisation plus temporaire avec sur
les différents projets que je mène en
fait
et puis ça me permet aussi de faire des
ateliers toujours avec un souci comme ça
de de partager la pratique artistique
dans différents cadres différents
milieux différents contextes
c'est important pour les enfants de se
rattacher à l'art de découvrir l'art ah
oui moi je veux je pense que c'est
vraiment tout à fait important de
prendre connaissance se déplie nationale
dès le plus jeune âge de notre
sensibilité qu'elle soit au niveau
visuel au niveau 2 du son par
l'apprentissage de la musique pourquoi
pas du goût aussi si on peut apprendre à
savourer je trouve que tout ce qu'on
peut nous apprendre à mieux faire ça
nous aide dans la vie énormément et et
ça nous permet d'apprécier la vie et
donc d'être plus fort je pense ce qui
vous inspire au quotidien au quotidien
c'est la lumière ça c'est sûr que j'ai
toujours un coin de l'oeil rivé sur la
météo
j'ai la chance de vie
dans dans un appartement justement de la
résidence louis lumière à guyancourt et
j'ai une grande baie vitrée qui me
permet vraiment de voir le mouvement de
la lumière
et ça ça me motive beaucoup donc la
lumière les couleurs ça c'est quelque
chose que je regarde quotidiennement oui
merci beaucoup c'est que le terreau
merci à vous merci à vous d'avoir suivi
cette émission à bientôt dans un nouveau
vite
[Musique]